-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for watching.
Thank you for being here.
Well, guys, today,
a group of leading U.S.
and international scientists
announced new data that shows
COVID booster shots are
not appropriate at this time.
[ Audience ohs ]
Yeah, and then scientists saw
100 sold-out football stadiums
this weekend
and were like, "Hold that
thought. Hold on a second."
Yep, they said
they're absolutely sure
of their findings
and look forward
to changing them next week.
[ Laughter ]
It seems like these scientists
can't make up their mind.
I say we just
split the difference
and just start
microdosing Pfizer.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
as if the Delta variant
isn't causing enough problems,
apparently, it's now led
to a shortage of printing paper.
-Oh.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is a big deal.
If this is true,
my dad will have no way
to print out his e-mails.
[ Laughter ]
"Hold on a second, Jimmy.
Let me read what you wrote.
Hold on a second."
The paper shortage is so bad,
book sellers are worried
there might not be enough paper
to print books.
See, this is what happens
when one out of three people
write a Trump tell-all.
That's what I've been saying.
Hey, everyone's got to stop
with the tell-alls.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, this is fun. Ahead of
the newest "James Bond" film,
one company
is looking to hire someone
to be an official
martini tester.
-Whoo!
-That sounds like a job
a contestant on
"The Bachelorette" would have.
Like, "Hi. My name's Todd B.
I'm an official martini tester."
[ Laughter ]
This wasn't good. Yesterday
at the Washington Football
Team's season opener --
That's the name.
They're sticking with that name.
The Washington
Football Team, yeah.
At the Washington
Football Team's season opener,
a pipe at the stadium burst
over a group of fans,
and some people said
it might have been sewage.
[ Audience groans ]
I don't know. Take a look.
-That's sewage.
-Ah.
-That's sewage?
-Well, that's a good omen
for the season, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Washington is still looking
for a team name,
and it's too bad the Browns
is already taken.
-Hey! Oh, oh!
Oh! Oh, hey!
-But the fans, the fans
embraced it all day long.
They were chanting, "We're
number one and number two!"
We're number --"
Ah, there you go.
[ Applause ]
This is interesting. I read
that emojis may be the new way
patients communicate
with their doctor.
I don't know. Do you really
want to receive bad news
from your doctor by getting
the thumbs-down emoji?
I -- Sounds a little strange,
but instead of having to explain
something embarrassing,
you could just send this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ow!
-Well, get this.
A team of scientists
are potty-training cows
in an effort to reduce the
emissions caused by their waste.
Which means stores are going
to start charging extra
for grass-fed, free-range,
potty-trained beef.
[ Laughter ]
What a job. Every night,
the scientists come home
smelling like
they just left the Washington
Football Team's stadium,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, last night,
Jon Stewart and Pete Davidson
put on a big benefit show
at Madison Square Garden
called "NYC Still Rising
After 20 Years."
And it was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good for them.
It was great.
I was there,
and I wrote a song for it,
and I'd like to play it for you
right now, if you don't mind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, bud.
Thank you.
Madison Square Garden,
how you guys doing?
[ Cheers and applause ]
My name is Jimmy Fallon.
I'm a New Yorker,
and I got a little song for you.
[ Guitar playing ]
♪♪
♪ I don't care
if you're Moderna or Pfizer ♪
♪ Johnson & Johnson
or horse tranquilizer ♪
♪ I know ♪
♪ New York's coming back ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ We got the Rangers, Yankees,
Mets, Knicks, and Nets ♪
♪ We cheer for the Giants
and we pray for the Jets ♪
♪ Well, I know ♪
♪ New York's coming back ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ We're already complaining
about the cold ♪
♪ We all hate Bill de Blasio,
and I know ♪
♪ New York's coming back ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ We got the NYPD and the FDNY ♪
♪ When I tried out, they said ♪
"You seem more like
a post office guy."
♪ So I know ♪
♪ New York's coming back ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ All the tourists
have returned ♪
♪ Doing what they do ♪
♪ Walking slowly
down the sidewalk ♪
♪ Right in front of you ♪
♪ Even though
some of the seats are wet ♪
♪ The subway is still packed ♪
♪ I know New York City's
coming back ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ New York is back,
you can't keep us down ♪
♪ You can travel the world ♪
But there's no place
like this town.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ So I know
New York City's back ♪
♪♪
♪ I know New York City's
coming back ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love you, New York!